apparently facebook took note of what  happened uh after they disabled the  instagram account of shauna chappelle  what the mother of uh kareem nikoi a  marine killed in afghanistan wow  shauna had previously posted criticism  of biden on facebook saying my son's  blood is on your hands which i think is  quite fair  instagram later restored her account  saying it had been disabled in error oh  sure oh  error  every time it's always an error when  they do it to a conservative  the algorithm gotcha well how is it yeah  how's it an error when somebody read it  and made a choice  yeah yeah that's not an error you just  did it it's an interesting error we  don't know how to think about it dude  you don't even have to not that voice  well